I'm Devin Larry my car yellow the king
of New York we're here with the world
armwrestling league and we are going to
talk about the finer points of how to
win an arm wrestling match so I guess we
can start from the bottom and work our
way up
there's many stances you can take but
most people will do a split stance the
arm that you're armwrestling it with the
same leg is gonna go forward this is
gonna create a brace so you can try off
the table with your hip to generate
force your left leg can move forward or
back to give you a variety of technical
choices
you want to hug the table you don't want
to be back here you want to get this
table you want to keep your arm and
elbow tight and usually your lat
basically obvious they tighten your
muscles you never want to be extended or
use your necks and people really don't
understand all nothing about just an arm
usually your whole body not just so very
important some other choices you'll see
a lot of arm wrestlers do is you'll see
them put their foot up so that they can
do more pressing techniques you'll see
them put both feet under so they can do
more backwards top rolling stop
techniques or even lift the off leg to
generate you know pressure through
through their body bag when it comes to
setting up you're always trying to get a
better grip normally the better grip is
determined by Heights and death so when
you talk about depth you see this line
created by the thumb where it intersects
my hand a deeper grip goes further past
and this is typically thought of as
advantageous for me and in counter to
that Mike would be coming up as well to
you know make his grip
one of the best ways to think about
armwrestling is you're attacking
weakness as opposed to thinking about
where you're strong a lot of people when
they first start armwrestling they
really just want to bring everything
close to them and push which is a great
choice but what you'll see more advanced
guys do is they're gonna start to target
where it's really uncomfortable for you
so they're gonna they're gonna hit
primarily your fingertips or the
pronation of your palm and this is what
we think about hand control yeah so if
you could he went in my fist I would
want to open his fingers this way using
a topical technique that's one way to
counteract you want to use your bones
and your frame a lot as well in the
sport of arm wrestling you want to have
everything in line so that you're able
to push with your frame in a in a safe
place if you're trying to push a match
and you're open this can create a spiral
through your humerus which which can be
dangerous so when you're setting up to
push you typically want to have your
elbow inside your body and you want to
have the angle from your shoulder to
your hand intersect your opponent's arm
if ever if ever so see Mike's arm right
now I just have more efficiency right
now I have more of my frame behind it
he's using just his arm I'm using my
body so that's another thing to think
about
basically any any angle you can secure
be it bending your wrist in pronating
getting your arms inside your body
getting your arm close to you is to your
advanced there's three waist or muscle
there's a hook everyone finds their
niche and where baby gets wrong a lot of
times when people start armwrestling
they think about the pin impact but most
pro arm wrestlers are actually thinking
more about pulling you away from your
body so as opposed to going to the side
they're trying to pull you across the
table get the match closer to yeah it's
like what are you doing it left at top
row it's like you're pouring a cup of
water with you